[Musique]
bien on débat sur france 24 la france
s'est réveillée devant une situation
politique inédite au lendemain du second
tour des élections législatives
emmanuel macron tout juste réélu va
avoir du mal à gouverner sa formation
politique n'a obtenu que 245 sièges loin
de la majorité absolue
il devra donc composer avec les
oppositions la nuque a obtenu 135 131
sièges dont 75 pour les insoumis le
rassemblement national apparaît comme le
grand gagnant avec 89 élus la droite
républicaine lr à 61 sièges le taux
d'abstention a battu un record une
nouvelle fois puisque un français sur
deux n'est pas allé voter la première
ministre elisabeth borne a été élu avec
une courte majorité elle reste donc chef
du gouvernement mais alors comment
va-t-elle gouverner comment finalement
trouvé des alliés pour faire passer les
textes
à gauche la coalition se fissure ps et
europe ecologie les verts et pcf refuse
maintenant la proposition de jean luc
mélenchon d'un groupe nuque unique à
l'assemblée les républicains feront
avant l'automne une série de
propositions distille sur divers sujets
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a affirmé
christian jacob qui comptent garder son
parti à l'initiative dans un rôle
d'opposition responsable dit il alors la
france est-elle devenue ingouvernable on
en parle avec mes invités j'ai plaisir
d'avoir mes côtés benjamin morel bonsoir
un choix politologue maître de
conférences en droit public à paris à
paris 2 merci d'être avec nous dans le
débat en face de vous thomas porte
bonsoir députés à la france a soumis aux
élus dans la troisième circonscription
de la seine-saint-denis merci d'être
avec nous bienvenue dans le débat en
face de vous presque en face de vous
béatrice julio roule roule au pardon
rouleau merci d'être avec nous députés
rassemblement national élu dans la
sixième circonscription de
seine-et-marne bienvenue dans le débat
nous avons avec nous thomas agassi ue
qui est avec nous donc par skype de lyon
député la république en marche vous êtes
réélu dans la 10e circonscription du
rhône et bienvenue à vous avant de
démarrer ce débat sachez également que
vous pouvez tous participé poser vos
questions sur les réseaux sociaux
hashtag
débat f24 on va d'abord et bien faire un
bilan à récit de cette journée avec
florent rodo et on en discute ensuite
ils sont insoumis socialistes
écologistes ou encore communiste élu
sous la bannière commune de la nuque les
131 députés de la grande alliance de
gauche seront ils encore ensemble sur
les bancs de l'assemblée nationale c'est
en tout cas le souhait de jean luc
mélenchon la nuque devrait se constituer
comme un seul groupe au parlement de
manière à ce que sans aucune discussion
possible il soit établi qui
mène l'opposition dans le pays
maintenant une idée immédiatement
rejetée par ses trois alliés à gauche le
parti socialiste europe écologie les
verts et le parti communiste mans du
confins sérieux revers pour le chef de
file de la nuque très inquiet de se
faire chiper la place de premier parti
d'opposition à emmanuel macron et la
présidence de la commission des finances
qui va avec car pour l'heure c'est bien
le rassemblement national et ses 89
députés qu'ils occupent élu dans le pas
de calais sa chef marine le pen sera à
l'assemblée pendant cinq ans ce qui ne
sera pas le cas de jean luc mélenchon
lui qui espère désormais ralliés à sa
cause des députés de gauche élu une
autre étiquette notamment ceux des outre
mer
derrière le trio de tête ensemble nuque
et rennes les républicains limite la
casse avec une soixantaine de députés
potentiel faiseur de roi ils disent
vouloir incarner une opposition
responsable
invité ce lundi sur le plateau de france
cette conseillère municipale l air
confirme nous serons dans une opposition
constructive
parce que nous ne participerons pas à
contrairement aux au parti extrémiste au
chaos du pays mais nous nous ferons
avancer les sujets pour les français des
républicains qui réunit cette semaine
leur bureau politique l'occasion de
clarifier une ligne politique devenue
illisible ces dernières années
benjamin morel va falloir donc gouverner
avec une majorité relative qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est un peu historique sous
la vème république
c'est assez historique en effet alors il
ya deux précédents de majorité relative
le premier précédent scellé tout début
de la vème république mais c'est un
moment particulier on est dans un moment
charnière de gaulle a été élu n'a pas
été le souhait sur au suffrage universel
à l'époque et vous avez une vie
politique ressemble beaucoup plus à
celle de la quatrième le deuxième
précédent historique c'est le
gouvernement rocard et ensuite cresson
et bérégovoy
il faut comprendre que à l'époque ça
fonctionne sur une base qui est une base
particulière parce que déjà michel
rocard gouverne à coups de 49 alinéa 3
ou savez cette disposition que les
français ont découvert ou en raid et on
va y revenir lynx des retraites et qui
vous permet de dire 'voilà soit vous
acceptez mon texte pour le gouvernement
soit vous voter une motion de censure à
l'époque michel rocard sentent s'en
sortent et parce qu' il pouvait en faire
un usage immodéré parce que vous avez
deux groupes qui s'abstenait
structurellement les communistes et les
centristes là le 49 panier à trois
étaient diminués en tout cas il était
délimitée dans son usage depuis 2008 et
il faudra encore que les autres groupes
politiques au sein de l'assemblée
s'abstiennent ce qui est loin d'être
évident donc il va falloir construire
des majorités haddock sur chaque texte
évidemment ça va être extrêmement
compliqué et là pour le coup est bien on
touche un effet un petit peu à la limite
de la pressent de la présente
gouvernance mais il faut quand même
nuancer un peu ce je dirais ce constat
assez à l'aise alarmiste la plupart des
pays européens fonctionne sur un modèle
de coalition à part nous les anglais
donc pourquoi pas la france pourquoi pas
là sans oublier le deuxième élément
c'est que michel debré était persuadé
qu'il n'y aurait jamais de majeur et
absolue à l'assemblée nationale que ça
ressemblerait beaucoup plus à la ivème
république et donc notre constitution a
été écrite construite armées pour lutter
contre ce type de situation en tout cas
pour permettre de le juguler de le
réguler donc en aucun cas aujourd'hui la
france sombre dans l'anarchie pas
d'anarchie selon-vous baja moral en tout
cas vous êtes plutôt optimiste on les
écoute et elisabeth bornes c'était hier
soir la première ministre
jamais l'assemblée nationale n'a connu
une telle configuration sous la vème
république
cette situation constitue un risque pour
notre pays au vu des défis que nous
avons à affronter
tant sur le plan national qu'à l'échelle
internationale
mais ce vote nous devons le respecter et
en tirer les conséquences
en tant que force centrale dans cette
nouvelle assemblée nous devons assumer
une responsabilité particulière
nous travaillerons dès demain à
construire une majorité d'actions et au
magasin où vous êtes député la
république en marche donc vous vous avez
été réélu dans la 10e circonscription du
rhône d'abord l'opposition a dit que
c'était une déroute pour le parti
présidentiel juste un commentaire là
dessus non je ne le pense pas ces serres
des résultats qui sont pas aussi
important que ce qu'on aurait souhaité
mais je pense que ce résultat c'est
surtout le résultat qui découle d'un
quinquennat de crise et d'une situation
inédite d'un premier la première fois on
a eu un président de la république qui a
été réélu hors cohabitation est donc
clairement l'élection présidentielle n'a
pas créé l'effet de souffle qui génère
habituellement le fait majoritaire et on
aboutit à un résultat finalement qui est
proche d'un scrutin proportionnel vous
allez devoir négocier donc pour chaque
réforme on l'a vu avec benjamin morel
qui n'a pas l'air très inquiets est ce
que vous êtes inquiet vous donc possible
paralysé à l'assemblée
écouter les électeurs ont tranché il
faut qu'on fasse avec et je souhaite
partager l'optimiste de benjamin morel
et chacun va devoir se dépasser en tant
que majorité on va devoir veiller à
mieux écouter mieux associer de prouver
sensibilité
et puis les oppositions vont aussi
devoir peut-être avoir des positions
moins caricatural ayant confiance dans
dans l'esprit de responsabilité des uns
et des autres en matière d bon compromis
pour le rugby parce qu'on partage les
objectifs communs réindustrialiser le
pays ont des services publics plus
efficaces accélérer la la transition
écologique est donc ce sont les français
qui jugeront et vous savez qu
effectivement notre constitution prévoit
des outils en cas de blocage le vote
bloqué le 49-3 bien entendu on ne
souhaite pas y recourir et je pense
qu'on peut arriver à avancer si chacun
fait preuve d'un esprit de
responsabilité l'esprit de
responsabilité thomas porte vous qui
êtes élus dont vous êtes un tout nouveau
à l'assemblée nationale député la france
insoumise donc cette partie de la nuque
vous vous êtes un peu déçu du score de
la nuque un peu comme le disent tous
vous attendre à mieux notre objectif
était d'imposer une cohabitation et de
faire de jean luc mélenchon de prix
ministre mais je crois qu'il faut
regarder les résultats on à 131 députés
je crois que si jolie et votre chiffre
on va finir mon avis un peu plus haut
avec des députés d'outre-mer si on
arrive à créer les conditions mais moi
je veux revenir sur une chose les
résultats d'hier c'est une défaite pour
le gouvernement c'est la première fois
qu'il n'y a pas de majorité absolue dans
ce pays et sa confiance qu'en disait le
24 avril au soir c'est à dire qu
emmanuel macron n'a pas de majorité dans
ce pays et que le second tour de
l'élection présidentielle avait répondu
à aucune question puisque une électrice
où on est acteur sur deux avait utiliser
le bulletin de vote marine emmanuel
macron pour battre marine le pen donc
aujourd'hui a pas de majorité ça va être
très difficile pour le président la
république est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
composer avec justement c'est ce que
vient de dire thomas agassi est ce que
vous seriez prêt à composer sur certains
textes sur certaines dispositions
d'entrée près évidemment à composer mais
quand j'entends le représentant de la
majorité dire que l'on partage des
objectifs évidemment qu'on partage les
mêmes objectifs notamment celui je
reprends qui a été cité de lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique et d'engager
le prix le pays dans une tradition
écologique je rappelle quand même qu'on
sort d'un quinquennat ou le président a
été condamné à deux reprises pour une
action climatique donc on voit bien que
les éléments de langage qui ne
correspondent pas à la réalité et en
tout cas nous on fera tout pour que les
politiques des monnaies le maquereau
elles seront pas mises en oeuvre parce
que je le redis ici a pas de majorité en
ce pays pour la retraite à 65 ans ça
n'existe pas vous ferez tout pour que ça
ne soit pas mis en avant ce que vous
dites jean luc mélenchon en tout cas à
lui souhaiterait que ce groupe ne reste
un groupe uni à l'assemblée
manifestement il ya déjà des fissures à
gauche puisque europe ecologie les verts
le parti socialiste et le parti
communiste s'oppose justement à ce
groupe unique nuque donc là ça veut dire
que si sa fille sur et bien vous ne
serez vous s'il vous restait pas groupé
c'est le rassemblement national qui va
devenir la première le premier groupe
d'opposition au sein de l'assemblée
d'abord il ya encore des discussions et
tout est sur la table et jean luc
mélenchon a fait une proposition que je
partage c'est à dire qu'on a été élu
sous une bannière politique et celle de
la nouvelle union populaire écologique
et sociale moi je suis venue de la
troisième circonscription de la
seine-saint-denis nous avons douze
députés les gens vont voter pour des
députés de la nuque donc ça serait tout
à fait légitime que nous ayons un groupe
ensemble à l'assemblée la délégation a
soumis ses 75 députés sûrement par les
autres vous n'êtes plus mais j'en ai par
exemple les offres sion qui est membre
du parti communiste et qui a été réélu a
appelé de ses voeux qui est un groupe
commun audrey pulvar qui est dans la
majorité socialiste anne hidalgo a
appelé de ses voeux à skis un groupe
commun et je crois que c'est l'intérêt
général qui doit primer et ça ne
m'empêchera pas de respecter la
diversité d orange ou à la diversité à
l'écran justement de la nuque
d'accord que nous avions passé avec les
autres forces politiques de gauche il y
avait quand même la proposition d'un
intergroupe donc c'est une traduction
qui peut se matérialiser sur un nouveau
groupe chacun aura des délégations ça se
fait déjà au parlement robin et je crois
que jean luc mélenchon en responsabilité
a raison d'appeler à la création de ce
groupe mais pour l'instant ça se fissure
savons pour l'instant les discussions
aux discussions fin tout cas ils ne
veulent pas de cette de ce groupe commun
en tout cas au ps à europe ecologie les
verts et également des f vous verrez de
rebond dans les prochains heures dont
vous vous restez vous restez optimiste
et je souhaite qu'ils ce groupe qui soit
créé à l'assemblée nationale et je pense
que la responsabilité des uns et des
autres débouchera sur une prod une
réponse positive béatrice rouleau
évidemment si ce groupe e ne se fissure
c'est le rassemblement national qui va
évidemment profité puisqu'il deviendra
là pour le coup le premier groupe
d'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
vous êtes aussi une toute nouvelle à
l'assemblée nationale alors je suis une
toute nouvelle à l'assemblée nationale
je suis conseillère régionale mais c'est
la première fois que je rentre à
l'assemblée nationale et monsieur noël
non
voilà et donc est donc et j'allais dire
enfin enfin un peu de démocratie
dans ce parlement lors de leur n 11 fois
plus de jeux tellement de l'unicef
sommes incontestablement le premier
groupe à l'assemblée nationale et nous
le resterons j'allais dire enfin
pourquoi parce que vous vous souvenez
que nous n'avions même pas de quoi
constituer un groupe je crois que nous
étions neuf députés un petit peu moins
après quand certains sont partis alors
que ma présidente représenté 10 millions
600 mille voix d'électeurs c'était un
des mots un déni de démocratie dont
chacun se satisfaisait aujourd'hui il y
a un peu plus de proportionnelle
paria par les fonctionnels du tout
voulait semble dangereux préfet
demandait je reprends vos commentaires
ça ressemble davantage à un scrutin qui
seraient issus de la proportionnelle
alors donc plus de démocratie je crois
qu'on peut s'en réjouir et absolument
pas sans inquiéter parce que le peuple
justement sera représentée moi ce que je
veux c'est souligner l'incohérence en
fait qd de la nubie quitté juste là pour
engranger des sièges et qui au lendemain
une fois qu'on a eu les sièges et bien
finalement chacun reprend sa
petite musique et chacun les socialistes
disent eux c'est nous les socialistes
les la france est soumise dit on et on
veut commander à votre avantage donc
donc c'est complètement à notre avantage
et ce n'est pas cohérent vis-à-vis des
électeurs et moi je ne m'étonne pas
qu'il y ait eu 89 députés élus de sous
la bannière rassemblement national parce
que nous sommes près des électeurs et
nous sommes qu'ils avaient été surprises
news probablement j'étais sur un an est
d'être au second tour mais pas du tout
après d'être élu et j'ai pas été
surprise du score moi je pensais alors
que vous avez souvent raison sur ce
point je pensais que vous n'aviez pas
raison si moi j'ai savouré la presse en
général l'art assassiné par les
descendeurs de sondeurs et moi je
m'attendais à plus de 50 sièges
personnellement on va écouter marine le
pen
parce que tout le monde considère que
c'est une victoire pour rassemblement
national oui nous demanderons tout ce à
quoi nous avons droit tout ce qui aurait
été accordée au premier groupe
d'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
donc la présidence de la commission des
finances bien sûr une vice-présidence
bien sûr parce que le groupe que nous
avons qui encore une fois le premier
groupe d'opposition de l'assemblée ne
transigera sur aucun des moyens qui lui
est accordée par la tradition ou par les
règles républicaines
pour pouvoir défendre les français elle
veut briguer la commission la présidence
de la commission des finances un
benjamin elle c'est un enjeu important
ça est normalement d'après enfin sous la
vème république il est en général c'est
le premier groupe d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale qui détient sept
présidents déjà ça ne date que de 2008
et c'est vrai que cette course à
l'échalote active est le premier groupe
d'opposition le specis de droits
parlementaires s'en étonne un petit peu
parce que comment ça se passe cette
présidence de la commission des finances
dont tout le monde parle en réalité dans
le règlement de l'assemblée nationale il
ya écrit que cette présidence de la
commission des finances revient à
l'opposition pas forcément au premier
groupe d'opposition à la vous en avez de
l illustré à droite et à gauche donc que
fait la majorité en règle générale est
bien la majorité sapiens elle s'abstient
et du coup elle laisse l'opposition
désigné le président de la commission
des finances a n'a rien à voir avec le
premier groupe évidemment le premier
groupe à plus de députés donc il peut
l'emporter mais si la nuque par exemple
à un intergroupe ou un seul groupe ça ne
change rien et en réalité là où c'est
encore extrêmement étonnant c'est que du
point de vue du droit parlementaire il
vaut beaucoup mieux avoir beaucoup de
groupes parce que lorsque vous avez un
groupe vous avez c'est un peu technique
mais une commission denquête parents
vous avez ce qu'on appelle à une niche
parlementaire c'est-à-dire une
possibilité de faire avancer vos
propositions de loi de manière annuelle
sur une demi journée excepté un googler
parlement reprend un peu plus ses droits
donc non mais c'est pas ça ça veut dire
que si vous avez un seul groupe vous
n'avez que ça une fois si vous n'avez 4
vous avez quatre fois s'avérer une banda
avait ce poste que vous avez deux
groupes plus vous avez des espaces
si jamais ça se joue comme ça devrait
jouer normalement il devrait en effet y
avoir une majorité qui s'abstient et les
députés d'opposition qui seront les plus
nombreux à se mettre derrière un
candidat ou une candidate devrait
l'emporter si la nuque à une seul et
même candidature elle peut l'emporter
face aux arènes ça ait l'air thomas
gaccio qu'est ce que vous pensez
justement de cette option pour la
présidence de la commission des finances
la majorité va s'abstenir cette fois et
laissez donc l'opposition briguent et on
verra bien vous savez l'installation des
députés encourent d'imprévus
administratif et tout ça va se passer la
semaine prochaine moi je pense que ce
qui est fondamental dans ce qu'on se dit
c'est finalement qu'on ne peut pas se
contenter d'une majorité à l'assemblée
pour réformer le pays il faut également
faire adhérer l'ensemble des forces
vives du pays et donc c'est plutôt 5
finalement des décisions se prennent
avec l'ensemble des forces politiques
qui doivent être représentés et c'est
pour ça que d'ailleurs je rappelle que
dans notre projet en 2017 on souhaitait
ajouter une dose de proportionnelle
finalement ça se fait j'allais dire par
face à nice et on va faire pardonner
mois thomas gayssip boys avant 5 ans
évoque notamment
mentionné
par le sénat est donc finalement on est
dans une situation
de quasi de quasi proportionnelle on
dispose on a la chance d'être un pays
qui dispose d'un président avec une
légitimité démocratique qui peut prendre
les grandes décisions pour le pays
notamment sur la scène internationale et
au niveau parlementaire maintenant nous
allons devoir insert par accident
apprendre la culture du du compromis
pour bâtir ensemble les grandes
décisions qui seront bonnes pour le pays
si vous n'êtes pas contre la culture du
compromis à vous entendre en tout cas
christian jacob le pape demande est le
patron et l'air pardonnez moi il a dit
pacte ni de coalition il va pas vous
rendre la vie facile finalement alors
que le lr aurait pu passer une coalition
avec vous déjà non mais écoutez j'ai été
élu local pendant plus de dix ans avant
d'être député dans l'ensemble des
exécutifs que j'ai dirigés ou auxquelles
j'ai participé il y avait des personnes
de droite avait des personnes des
écologistes et à chaque fois quand on a
pu échanger quant à lui la culture du
compromis on a été capable de prendre
des bonnes décisions pour l'être pour le
territoire je constate que les paysages
les autres pays européens y arrive donc
je fais confiance en l'esprit de
responsabilité des uns et des autres
pour arriver à construire des majorités
de projets finalement c'est un peu
l'histoire qui nous bousculent et je
pense qu'il faut qu'on saisit cette
occasion pour ensemble finalement tenter
de parvenir à trouver ces grands
compromis qui notamment jeu j'en suis
sûr nous permettront d'avancer sur par
exemple la transition écologique car
j'en ferais je ferais justement réagir à
ce que vous venez de dire nos députés
d'opposition sur ce plateau mais avant
cela on retrouve armand zorn député au
bundestag
député du spd vous êtes à bruxelles avec
nous en direct bonsoir à vous alors en
allemagne évidemment c'est un autre
système un système parlementaire on
n'est pas du tout dans ce régime
présidentiel à la française les
coalitions vous connaissez très bien
puisque le dernier d'ailleurs vous
mettez du temps obama a finalement avoir
un chef de gouvernement tellement ça
devient n'est pas si simple est-ce
comment est ce que vous regardez vous
justement la france ce qui se passe en
france ça vous paraît normal finalement
qu' on se retrouve avec un pays qui
doivent trouver des coalitions
si vous voulez moi je pense qu'en fait
la réalité politique les réalités
politiques ont bien rattrapé le système
politique en france parce que le système
majoritaire qui est défavorable pour les
petits partis politiques en france je
trouve qu'il est arrivé à ses limites
c'est ce qu'on voit lien et je pense que
quand on voit tous les enjeux qu'on voit
tous les challenges auxquels on fait
face aujourd'hui que ce soit en
allemagne que ce soit en france que ce
soit aussi à l'échelle européenne
je pense qu'il faut vraiment un système
qui kim à une entente en place qu'il est
un compromis qui rend compte pour mieux
possible pour vraiment résoudre ces
problèmes malgré le fait qu'on allemagne
on voit aussi un petit peu les limites
de ce compromis comme je le disais
combien de mois avez vous mis avant
d'avoir un chef de gouvernement
et comment ça se passait autour d'un
projet avec ça marche c'est ça
ben si vous voulez on a souvent tendance
à se plaindre un peu du système
politique en allemagne mais au final je
pense qu'on est quand même très fiers de
notre système politique la constitution
allemande des demandes des partis
politiques des groupes politiques de
travailler ensemble dont sortent une
campagne électorale où chaque parti
politique a bien sûr sa campagne
électorale à bien ses projets mais après
les élections puisque c'est clair que
aucun parti n'aura la majorité absolue
les partis politiques sont dans forcer à
négocier sont renforcés à définir un
projet commun un projet pas seulement
pour le parti politique pour l'ensemble
de la république fédérale et au final
moi je trouve que quand vous voyez les
décisions qui sont prises ça met du
temps c'est compliqué c'est des
compromis mais la majorité des décisions
que les gouvernements allemands prennent
ont bien une majorité pas seulement une
majorité politique l'oci une majorité de
la société donc vous voyez vous avec les
défenses majeur de la société qui sont
derrière ces décisions prises et je
pense que ça qui est vraiment important
surtout quand on vit dans une tradition
comme c'est qu'on fait face en ce moment
c'est une marque de démocratie benjamin
morel est ce que ça peut vraiment
s'appliquer en france parce qu'on était
mou finir on était franchement déjà même
étonné de voir que les allemands vous
avez à la fois le spd donc la
social-démocratie les verts et puis le
parti libéral alors que a priori ils
n'avaient rien en commun surtout pas les
verts et le parti libéral ils ont réussi
à se mettre à se mettre ensemble sur un
projet très spécifique ça peut arriver
en france véritablement oui mais vous
avez une solution en fait qui est liée
au mode de scrutin quellier à la
proportionnelle or là on en effet on a
un scrutin majoritaire mais on a en
effet plutôt proportionnelle mais en
réalité quand vous regardez en effet les
enquêtes transnationales notamment sur
l'allemagne vous voyez que le taux de
satisfaction vis-à-vis des politiques
publiques est beaucoup plus important
tout bêtement parce que qu'angela merkel
gouverne avec une coalition de céder ou
c'est sous spd vous avez à peu près un
allemand sur deux qui a voté pour les
partis de la mise en culture du
compromis seront contraints ils sont
contraints à cette culture du compromis
c'est à dire que en règle générale vous
n'avez pas de majorité pléthorique en
france vous avez des majorités
pléthorique de manière structurelle donc
on n'est pas habitué à ça par ailleurs
vous avez l'élection du président de la
république on parle beaucoup d'une
alliance potentielle avec l air mais
pour à l'air en 2027 c'est difficile
d'envoyer un candidat à la
présidentielle qui assumerait le bilan
des manuels macron donc le fait
justement de devoir présenter un
candidat demain fait que les marges de
manoeuvre pour établir des compromis
sont structurellement difficiles d'où
une vie politique est beaucoup plus
conflictuel thomas porte c'est vrai que
la vie politique française est beaucoup
plus conflictuel que outre-rhin par
exemple on va prendre un exemple concret
il ya ce texte sur le pouvoir d'achat
c'est le premier texte a priori que
voudrait adopter la majorité
présidentielle donc c'est un texte est
ce que vous pourriez le voter il ya
prolongement pour résumer un bouclier
tarifaire sur l'énergie à nouveau
dispositif sur le prix de l'essence pour
les gros rouleurs la suppression de la
redevance audiovisuelle
la revalorisation des retraites
peut-être mais c'est encore à disques en
discussion à chèques alimentaires ce que
vous pourriez de voter mais on verra le
contenu exact du test du texte bardon
puisque vous avez donné quelques
éléments on est pas encore on sait pas
encore ce cas deux ans mais déjà les
premières tendances pour nous ils sont
pas à la hauteur de la situation on est
sur d'autres mesures servent du blocage
des prix celle d'aller taxer les grandes
multinationales notamment total qui ont
profité de la crise pour s'enrichir et
verser un milliard de dividendes aux
actionnaires quand les françaises et les
français voient les factures augmenter
mais vous avez parlé de compromis et de
discussions mais je rappelle quand même
qu'au second tour après le second tour
de la présidentielle bruno le maire
était sur les plateaux télé pour dire
attention si ça va pas assez vite on
mettra en place le 49-3 notamment sur la
réforme des retraites donc voilà
aujourd'hui la réalité de la retraite
vous l'avez très jamais bien sûr mais je
dis ça regardez le travail des dix sept
députés de la france est soumise à
l'assemblée nationale sur les cinq
dernières années nous avons déposé des
milliers d'amendements des milliers de
propositions de loi et je crois qu'ils
avaient des amendements des propositions
de loi qui répondait à l'intérêt général
et par dogmatisme là aussi la majorité
n'avaient pas voté quasiment qu'un donc
on voit aussi que celles et ceux qui
parlent de compromis ne l'appliquent pas
qu arrive sur nos affaires et je le
redis ce président de la république n'a
pas de majorité moi je suis surpris
d'ailleurs qu'elisabeth demande reste
première ministre après les résultats
des élections législatives je suis pas
tout à fait sûr que vous soyez prêt à la
compromis au compromis pardon à la
compromission j'ai un lien qu'on premier
surnom et au compromis s'il va dans le
sens de l'intérêt général et des besoins
des françaises et français pourquoi pas
mais il faut avoir le contenu des textes
béatrice rouleau quant à vous alors
pouvoir d'achat c'est la première mais
ces mesures c'est la mesure phare de
marine le pen donc a priori le sujet
nous intéresse puisque c'est nous qui
l'avons proposé en premier alors il vous
propose et bien d'autres choses que à
lorient dans leur excuse est intéressant
pour lesquels et les électeurs
évidemment nous ont suivi ont proposé
nous la baisse de la tva sur les
boutiques projet des bandes c'est pas du
tout projet donc c'est pour ça que si on
doit discuter ce projet je pense qu'on
aura notre pierre à apporter a pris moi
je voudrais simplement souligner une
chose c'est que ma présidente est une
femme intelligente et pragmatique et
mesure et quoi qu'on en dise je vous
mets au défi dans son programme de
trouver une mesure extrême et si et si
et si la sq a opposé pas le même
programme
et si la mesure proposée je voudrais
juste terminer ma phrase et si la mesure
est bonne pour le peuple français parce
que c'est de cela dont il s'agit et bien
je ne vois pas pourquoi mam président ne
voterai pas un texte qui serait bon pour
les français ce sera un peu au qatar
mais s'il n'y a pas de baisse de tva par
exemple je n'en voyais je peux vous en
parler à sa place donc je pense que vous
aurez le plaisir de l'invité et elles
voudront elle vous répondra et surtout
nous nous réunirons nous en sommes au
début mais voilà quel est le principe
c'est à dire que de toute façon le
pouvoir d'achat est heureuse que
monsieur macro on est heureux plutôt
comme ce maquereau et repris ce thème
puisque c'était notre thème de campagne
en premier est évidemment les
propositions qui seront bonnes d'où ne
feront pas dodo d'obstruction stéroïdes
c'est ce que je voulais dire pas d'ogm
et les sens mais nous défendrons le
peuple français c'est à dire que nous ne
sommes pas systématiquement des
revendications comme peut l'être la
française thomas guessihio alors
justement une réaction de votre part
comment obtenir des compromis avec
justement rassemblement national et la
nuque qui ont vraiment y compris son
pouvoir d'achat des projets extrêmement
différent du vôtre
est-ce que vous allez reprendre les
textes c'est ce que vous allez y et
ajouté des dispositions
alors peut-être pas sur la
revalorisation du smic parce que mais
peut-être sur d'autres par exemple la
baisse de la tva sur les produits de
première nécessité ça c'est une des
propositions du rassemblement national
goudé je pense qu'on va les pousser à
adopter chacun un nouveau logiciel
politique effectivement en essayant
davantage les uns et les autres de se
consulter avant même les textes pour
essayer de dégager les grands compromis
la conclusion tout ça c'est qu'aucun
système politique n'est parfait et l'a
finalement par accident on va peut-être
progresser avec un système plus
proportionnelle on en tirera les
conséquences eux dans quelques années
puisque vous savez qu'on doit faire
également une réforme institutionnelle
et moi j'ai confiance sur le fait que si
chacun faire l'effort ça ça peut
fonctionner quand l'intérêt du pays est
en jeu
chacun de recroiser passé je peux vous
dire que j'ai été aidé par d'années -
excusez-moi je vous interromps lorsque
les projets à proportionnelle il faut
s'il aurait fermé sur des sur des choses
aussi simples que pouvoir d'achat encore
une fois les projets sont diamétralement
opposés non écouter l'opposition
des uns et des autres qui ont pu
s'exprimer il va être pour ne pas faire
un bouclier tarifaire qui va être contre
la suppression d'un nouveau studio
visual qui va être content revaloriser
les retraites les français vont nous
regarder et qui osera s'opposer contre
telle ou telle mesure d'autant plus si
on les a on construit encore une fois
j'ai vécu cinq ans oula je veux déjà
thomas por qué pas l'air du tout
d'accord avec ce que vous dites eh ben
il la suivra devant ses électeurs j'ai
vécu cinq ans ou lors des déplacements
internationaux avec des députés les
filles parfois des députés et rennes
nous étions en mesure parfois parce que
l'intérêt du pays l'exigé d'avoir des
positions communes à peine nous étions
rentrés en france que tout d'un coup
nous étions totalement opposé je crois
que nous avons la capacité de dépasser
les clivages parce que l'intérêt
supérieur du pays est en jeu et les
prochaines semaines seront très
instructive à ce sujet là et vous verrez
et je pense que on sera en mesure de
progresser et en l'occurrence le
discours de politique générale de la
première ministre puisque elisabeth
borne donc qui va le faire il me semble
c'est le 5 juillet c'est ça ça ne me
trompe pas ces 5 juillet il ya déjà donc
une motion de censure qui devrait être
déposé en tout cas par eric coquerel
c'est le cas en tout cas il va le faire
c'est la formation je pense que ça va
être on va aboutir là dessus vous savez
je
dis juste une chose on parle là c'est du
résultat des élections on dit que c'est
un peu c'est quelque part j'ai entendu
le mot c'est un accident ou un cadre
démocratique non c'est une réalité
électorale qui a parlé hier et qui
montrent que le pays est extrêmement
divisé qui a pas de majorité je leur dit
ici si vous voulez si vous voulez aller
dans la salle si vous voulez aller dans
le sens de l'intérêt général grande
censure ça n'est pas le compromis pour
le coup ça ce sont les d'ailleurs ce
sont les instruments français mais on
utilise les éléments qui sont à notre
disposition mais moi je le redis ici
quand un gouvernement mène campagne et
qu'on a quand même des représentants de
la macro ni je pense à christophe
castaner qu'ils aient battu on a eu jean
michel blanc car au premier tour et
qu'on n'a pas de majorité absolue et qui
est un désaveu dans les urnes il
faudrait s'interroger moi je pense
qu'ils les avaient une bande devrait
démissionner de son poste près ministre
on ne peut pas rester premier ministre
après ce qui est quand même une défaite
électorale pour emmanuel macron et la
réplique en marche thomas guyot va
écouter une élection même présidentielle
n'a jamais tant les différences qu'ils
pouvaient
avoir lieu dans un pays simplement avant
il y avait un souffle majoritaires
puisqu'ils y avait une proximité des
élections légistatives des élections
présidentielles parce que souvent il y
avait des nouveaux présidents et donc ce
souffle majoritaire souffle a
suffisamment fort pour que le fait
majoritaire au sable effectivement
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
nouvelle et je pense que chacun d'entre
nous sera en mesure de se hisser un peu
plus haut que son propre sa propre
appartenance partisane pour tenter de de
trouver des solutions ensemble et
franchement j'ai l'espoir que une fois
que nous sont trouvés ces positions
ensemble le pays il ya des rats d'autant
plus facilement que personne n'aura donc
en garde elisabeth bornes pour l'instant
il n'est pas question
comme le demandent justement thomas
porte qu'elle quitte son passé et
peut-être qu'il faut sortir des
questions de personnes ce qui compte
encore une fois c'est ce qu'on fait pour
le pays et donc ayant tous cette volonté
de faire avancer les pays et je pense
qu'on croit s'en sortir amazon justement
en allemagne vous avez cette pratique on
dit que c'est une culture du compromis
en allemagne quels conseils vous pouvez
donner à la classe politique française
si vous permettez je pense que
personnellement il faut une réforme
constitutionnelle parce que là on s'en
rend bien compte que le système
politique ne fonctionne plus je trouve
que c'était un truc qui s'est un peu
montré dans ces années mais avec ce
dernier élections parlementaires
législatif on voit bien que ça ne
fonctionne plus et à le deuxième conseil
si je peux me permettre
il faut s'organiser des majorité au sein
de l'assemblée au sein de la société
l'idée qu'il ya un parti politique qui
l'avenir avec un programme et ce
programme aura vraiment le support de la
majorité absolue des français ça me
semble quand même assez un peu
dépassés si vous voulez donc je pense
qu'il faut vraiment une réforme
politique je pense que c'est aussi
vraiment une chance pour la classe
politique pour le système politique en
france donc j'invite vraiment tous mes
collègues franco à tous mes collègues
français et françaises a à travailler
vers cette refonte des réformes alors
d'abord un mot sur cette réforme
constitutionnelle benjamin morel dont on
parle depuis cinq ans d'ailleurs et qui
pourrait peut-être voir le jour pendant
ce nouveau quinquennat c'est le paradoxe
est la première victime d'hier parce que
pour avoir une réforme fonctionne elle
vous avez deux nécessité d'abord avoir
une majorité conformes à l'assemblée et
au sénat donc il faudrait que le sénat
vote conforme ce qui est loin d'être
évident il faudra trouver ensuite soit 3
5e des députés soit organisé un
référendum trouvé trois cinquièmes des
députés ça veut dire que actuellement
ensemble plus l air au sénat et à
l'assemblée n'ont pas cette majorité
donc c'est un petit créneau l'intérêt
est très large ce serait très compliqué
mais petite lueur d'espoir on parler de
terreur la proportionnelle la
proportionnelle ce n'est pas du domaine
constitutionnel ça peut passer par une
loi ordinaire et donc il est possible en
revanche assez facilement de changer le
mode de ce qu'est ce qu'elle reste la
priorité aujourd'hui la proportionnelle
alors qu'on voit oui mais on voit les
résultats à l'assemblée nationale sans
proportionnelle oms n'a plus besoin
alors c'est quand même très particulier
qui s'est passé hier une autre élection
demain ne reproduirait pas forcément on
risque de retrouver des vagues
majoritaire donc oui la proportionnelle
à ce stade dame apparaît nécessaire mais
la très trop l'eau oui monsieur m'a
compte pour nos porte quand même une
certaine responsabilité à avoir promis
la proportionnelle dans son programme de
2017 et à ne pas l'avoir fait donc il
est urgent que la loi change de ce point
de vue là et et nous souhaitons aussi
nous un référendum d'initiative
citoyenne qui sera 1 2v pour beaucoup de
réformes thomas porte alors ça va très
forte constitutionnel vous y êtes
favoris logiques voilà pour la question
personnelle et je crois que tous les
partis sont plus ou moins favorables
voilà on va être un projet mais mme
emmanuelle macro l'avait promis et c'est
pas la seule promesses qu'il n'a pas
tenues mêlant la cl si elle est
représentée on verra le contenu moi je
me prononce pas sur le contenu d'un
texte sans l'avoir sous les yeux mais la
proportionnelle et la promener de la
contre ça pourrait être justement un des
uns des projets l'utilisation du 49-3
thomas gars si lyon s'est tout de même
que ça va être larmes qui peut être
utilisée alors c'est vrai qu'elle est
encadré ce que et benjamin morel
manifestement on a le droit d'utiliser
une fois pour le budget est encore une
fois par session parlement donc ça fait
deux fois par session parlementaire
c'est ça je pense que j'ai contrôlé ans
perdent la sécurité sociale aussi donc
ça peut être un peu plus et puis vous
avez des sessions extraordinaires durant
l'été mais ça ne fait malgré tout pas
une méthode de gouvernement oui mais
peut-être thomas castilloux 16 peut-être
qu'il y aura recours la première
ministre à ce 49 3 pour faire passer ses
projets effectivement le fait
majoritaire n'avait pas tellement été
prévu par les fondateurs de la vème
république et la constitution regorge
d'outils mise à disposition pour le
gouvernement pour faire passer des
textes en cas de blocage mais il faut
pas commencer à la discussion alors qu
on démarre tout juste le mandat
législatif en parlant de ses outils
encore une fois je pense qu'on est en
mesure de dégager des majorités de
projet vous voyez on parlait de la
proportionnelle il faut qu'on ait ce
débat clairement nous on était pour une
proportionnelle partiel d'autres ronde
ou non peut-être une proportionnelle
intégrale ce qui est vraiment très
positif c'est que dans les années qui
arrivent on va avoir une occasion
d'expérimenter une assemblée un peu plus
représentative des des poids politique
de chacun et on aura l'occasion
d'expérimenter si la classe politique
c'est être à la hauteur de cette
nouvelle situation mais en justement sur
la réforme des retraites un tome agacé
où il est clair que vous n'avez pas du
tout de même projet que ni eau et rennes
ni à la france a soumise à la nuque
c'est très différent à la retraite à 65
ans est votre projet donc celui de
emmanuel macron et éventuellement l air
mais pas les autres avant j'avais bien
fait de dire qu'effectivement le projet
de réforme des retraites portée par les
élèves est assez proche du nôtre vous
avez noté également que l air plus
majorité permettait d'avoir une majorité
et donc si sur ce projet là il faut
qu'on avantages qu'on avance davantage
avec les l'air pour obtenir une majorité
générer un consensus on le fera on sera
pragmatique pour aucun parc à avancer
avec toutes les bonnes volontés et
pourquoi elle isabelle borne à l'air si
inquiète lorsqu'elle a fait son discours
hier mais on avait l'air heureuse ouvert
on est face à une situation nouvelle qui
n'a pas été pensé et pour lequel on n'a
pas installé des joutes des outils
juridiques mais qui se provoque par une
une un faisceau de particuliers on va
dire qu'il ne se reproduira plus
peut-être d'ailleurs voilà donc on est
face à une situation nouvelle qui est
non anticipés et là encore une fois
faisons du positif avec cette situation
nouvelle et ce sera l occasion d et si
l'ensemble de la classe politique est en
mesure de développer cette culture du
compromis et ce sera un très bon
exercice avant une éventuelle réforme
nationale mais la retraite à 65 ans
enfin non évidemment donc ça c'est non
non mais je dis une chose la retraite à
65 ans est minoritaire dans le pays les
derniers sondages que je suis sorti l'a
tué c'est pas les sondages de la france
est soumise ni de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et social s'était à
l'époque le jdd qui dit que 77% des
français voulaient la retraite à 60 ans
donc il ya pas mal il n'y a pas de
majorité claire et si elisabeth demander
si inquiète c'est qu'elle sait qui a pas
de majorité pour un certain nombre
d'idées du courant des moniales macro et
ce gouvernement sur les cinq dernières
années n'a pas brillé par le compromis
c'est pas une méthode de gouvernement
qui était expérimenté par emmanuel
macron depuis cinq ans donc ils savent
pas faire ils ont pas cette volonté là
et donc sur la réforme des retraites à
65 ans pour nous c'est clair que c'est
non et vous on ne sait pas trop
d'ailleurs on verra les messieurs macron
parce que monsieur macro changer de
position quelques jours avant les
élections donc déjà ne connais pas trop
de le projet 64 ans 61 ans n'hésite on
ne sait pas bon donc nous en tout cas
clairement au rassemblement national
nous sommes pour la retraite à 60 ans
quand on a commencé à travailler jeunes
super u comme un donneur est logique la
communanuté
alors ses 40 ans de toute façon nous on
est un peu plus voyez on est un peu plus
souffler un peu plus pragmatique donc
sans répondre à ma question sur les
ennuis de combien invités comme la
france est soumise aux ses 40 noeuds 40
annuités lors la route à 60 ans pas sûr
c'est la retraite à 60 ans quand on a
commencé jeune ça veut dire quoi comment
ces jeunes
écoutez ça nous paraît pas logique quand
on a commencé par exemple à travailler à
16 ans effectivement qu'on ait une
retraite à 65 ans donc
enfin en tout cas on n'arrivera pas à
vous mettre d'accord avec le projet
présidentiel s'il y ait eu que donc l
air qui n'est pas représentée sur ce
plateau qui pourrait effectivement voté
ce projet réellement à l'air mais ça va
pas être si facile que ça c'est à dire
qu'il n'est pas certain que quand sont
plus et l'air face une majorité là
dessus tout bêtement parce que l air va
vouloir poser ses conditions horizon va
vouloir poser ses conditions qui vont à
des conditions drastiques mais du côté
des députés renaissance qui sont dans
des circonscriptions de centre gauche et
qui pour certains sont passés à 100 ou
200 gwh après hier faire ce cadeau là à
l air c'est une condamnation à mort pour
2027 donc ce que vous gagnez à droite on
pouvait dans cette coalition en tout cas
dans cette alliance haddock le perdre à
gauche donc un projet de loi sur la
retraite va être extrêmement compliqué
d'autant que dans l'histoire quand vous
avez des phénomènes d'obstruction qui
fonctionne ils ont toujours trois
piliers d'abord une une majorité a fait
une opposition qui sait faire de
l'obstruction les oppositions à
l'assemblée nationale ça faire de
l'obstruction amenez vos regards
l'occasion de le faire et voir un
mouvement dans l'art qui est capable de
faire monter la mayonnaise durenque
l'obstruction alliés au parlement et une
majorité qui se divise sur le projet et
l'a en effet tous les ingrédients sont
là pour qu'un tel projet face exposée au
sein même de la majorité les coalitions
place thomas gaza youth donc ça pourrait
faire exploser la majorité on voit
d'ailleurs on a un schéma en ce moment à
l'antenne on voit comment est composée
justement ensemble 160 des pubs le
député la république en marche 28
horizon me semble-t-il si je me trompe
pas et 48 modem c'est bien ça donc
effectivement eu un potentiel là aussi
d'éclatement sur le projet de la
retraite à 65 ans le il a été indiqué
que l'horizon n'était pas en phase avec
nous sur la question de la retraite je
crois qu'on est on est tous en phase sur
ce sur projet de réforme du système des
retraites on est aussi très ouvert pour
éventuellement adapter
quelques quelques éléments le président
l'a montré pendant la campagne
électorale et donc non va-t-il mettre
d'accord les nerfs d'un côté horizon de
l'autre modem plus la république en mars
et les appels exigeant son amant elle
c'est l'essence du pouvoir politique et
c'est l'essence des discussions à
l'assemblée nationale de régler les
grandes contradictions qui traversent
notre pays et donc oui on va peut-être
davantage discuté à l'assemblée
nationale oui le fait qu'on était ultra
majoritaire on nous ont peut-être
minerai dans notre capacité de discuter
avec les uns et les autres mais je pense
que cela a été le cas de tout le monde
vous savez quand on est des élus et les
fi ouverts qu'ils héritent des
collectivités ils font pas preuve d'un
grand sens de d'un grand sens du
compromis dans les collectivités qui
dirige est donc cette nouvelle situation
va pousser chacun à davantage de
discussions parce qu'on a tous envie de
faire avancer le pays évidemment au
niveau local ce n'est pas la même chose
qu'au niveau national ça me faut aussi
le répéter benjamin morel un mot sur
l'a10 solution possible de l'assemblée
nationale aura ses larmes absolu du
président
ahmad double tranchant ça veut dire
qu'il peut dissoudre et en plus c'est il
peut le faire quand il veut il peut
dissoudre l'assemblée nationale ce qui
provoquerait des élections de nouvelles
élections alors il peut le faire quand
il veut il peut pas y avoir un an il
doit y avoir mais maximum minimum un an
pardon entre de dissolution donc là il
pourrait le faire demain mais si le fait
de demain faudra attendre 2023 à la même
date plus un jour pour qu'ils puissent
redit soudre si ça devient intenable
s'il n'arrive pas à voir les coalitions
s'il ne peut pas faire passer ses
réformes ça reste l'armé absolue dans sa
seule arme absolue mais encore faut-il
qu'elles ne vous reviennent pas en
boomerang c'est ce qui se passe pour
jacques chirac en 1997 c'est à dire que
si vous avez un gouvernement de votre
couleur politique qui est assez
impopulaire et que vous faites une
dissolution vous avez toutes les chances
d'avoir une majorité qui vous et encore
moins à une assemblée qui vous encore
moins favorable après la dissolution
donc il faut vraiment qu'il y ait une
occasion où tout d'un coup vous êtes
miraculeusement populaire pour tout d'un
coup dissoudre et espérer avoir une
majorité est loin de la coupe aux lèvres
ou trop paralysés ou trop paralysé mais
ensuite ce que vous pouvez faire c'est
le paradis vous savez 1997 c'est quoi
1997 c'est jacques chirac qui dit moi la
majorité était en 1993 les composants
majorité de partisans d'edouard balladur
je ne peux pas gouverner avec des
balladuriens je veux une majorité
chiraquienne il dissout des majorités de
gauche et ça s'appelle la troisième
cohabitation
finalement il s'en est pas mal le tir et
puisqu'elle a été réélu et après jacques
chirac en orient
ce n'est pas le but d'être élu le but
c'est de dire plus macro on ne peut pas
être élu mains puisque en 2027 on peut
faire que deux mandats successifs
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
vous sais gré d'un instrument très vème
république la vème république et puis je
portais ce qui a été dit c'est souvent
ça revient dans l'effet inverse parce
qu'il ya aussi les électrices et les
électeurs qui ont le sentiment que leur
vote est pas respectée puisque si
emmanuel macron choix dissous dans
quelques jours c'est à dire il renvoie à
celles et ceux qui ont voté pour leur
candidat indien se dissout dans six
mois ils vont peut-être changer je ne
crois pas
la dissolution aujourd'hui l'état actuel
puisque en plus il faut pour gagner une
majorité être un président populaire ce
qui est loin d'être le cas des monnaies
le maquereau aujourd'hui pétrisseur oui
tout à fait il pourrait se retrouver
avec plus du tout de majorité même pas
relative donc va-t-il changer à
dissoudre je n'en suis pas certaine
thomas gaci où il va songer à dissoudre
emmanuel macron si effectivement vous ne
parvenez pas à des compromis avec
français seront témoins du comportement
des uns et des autres et de leur volonté
de faire ou pas avancer le pays la
dissolution c'est une sorte d'épée de
damoclès qui pèse sur la tête de chaque
député et c'est toujours un échec de
devoir l'utiliser donc vous voyez moi
l'addition la dissolution j'avais plus
comme une dissuasion sur le fait de dire
si vous en tant que député vous ne
mettez pas vos positions au politicienne
les uns les autres au placard pour
essayer de construire des grands
compromis le pe au pays pour le pays va
voir le pays le président pour
connaissent août mais bien entendu ce
sera un échec de devoir il irait courir
aux coureurs un échec ce devoir recourir
bergeal maman elle vous êtes d'accord
avec ça mais ça reste l'armé absolue il
faut le savoir et moyen terme et que je
permets une arme qui est réellement à
double tranchant mais elle aurait un
effet intéressant c'est à dire qu'on a
beaucoup parlé de l'effet de vagues etc
il ya un problème aujourd'hui kelly au
quinquennat qu'est le télescopage des
calendriers en fait pourquoi ce qui est
des majorités pétrole pour le président
de la république parce que les élections
législatives arrivent est strictement
derrière les présidentielles si jamais
vous décorer les deux que les deux
calendriers et bien à ce moment là vous
n'avez plus cet effet là et il n'y a pas
besoin de voir revenir elle tenait une
dissolution peut suffire parce que du
coup mécaniquement vous les décors et
les laissant venir un septennat on
pourrait aussi merci fera jamais morel
d'avoir été avec no mercy thomas porte à
fait merci également béatrice ce rouleau
merci à vous au noma agassi you merci à
marmande horn d'avoir été avec nos actes
de bruxelles merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivi le reste avec nous sur
france 24